if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see i was dumbledore
that would be my brother
the world as we know it is coming undone
grindelwald's pulling it apart with hate
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous wizard in over a
century
a major zoologist his indispensable
assistant
wizard descended from a very old family
a school teacher
and
a muggle
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
are you kidding me right now
who wouldn't like our
[Music]
chances i have to save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
but delicately
i'm swiveling right you're serving
[Music]
begin
today
what is this place
the room we require
[Music]
correct three points to hufflepuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very dangerous it's very powerful i've
gotten wrong hands you know
i messed you up where did you guess it
i got for christmas
[Music]
you